el Ministerio del interior español sale
ileso de la investigación abierta sobre
las al menos 23 muertes sucedidas Hace
seis meses en El Paso fronterizo de
melilla la fiscalía ha decidido eximir
de cualquier responsabilidad tanto al
ministerio como a las fuerzas de
seguridad del estado que presenciaron la
tragedia según esta la actuación de los
agentes fue proporcionada ante la
agresividad de las personas que trataban
de cruzar tampoco considera que se
cometiera ningún delito de omisión del
deber de Socorro Pese a que según
testimonios de supervivientes los
migrantes estuvieron horas al sol
amontonados y heridos sin recibir ningún
tipo de ayuda de esta manera la fiscalía
da por buenas las explicaciones
marroquíes sobre las muertes y respalda
también las declaraciones que ha
mantenido durante meses el ministro del
interior español Fernando grande
marlaska que defendió el actuar español
pese a las críticas de miembros del
gobierno de coalición de la oposición y
hasta del defensor del pueblo además la
fiscalía avala las más de 470 llama
devoluciones en caliente que se hicieron
personas a quienes se les negó la opción
de pedir refugio o asilo pese a provenir
de países en conflicto la fiscalía
reconoce que las autoridades están
obligadas a facilitar estos trámites y
así evitar que intenten cruzar de manera
ilegal un informe de la ong caminando
fronteras revela que unas seis personas
han muerto cada día intentando cruzar
desde el continente africano hacia
España en los últimos 5 años